[Musique]
pour rencontrer maurice est si doux il
faut monter jusqu'à ce petit village aux
trois quarts abandonnée à l'entrée du
vercors side où habite en plein coeur du
village dans les bâtiments de l'ancienne
école où ils sont allés tous les deux
[Musique]
maurice lui reste accroché à la ferme
familiale qui se trouve légèrement à
l'écart du bourg même ils sont toujours
ensemble
si maurice n'est pas chez lui c'est
qu'il est chez sea doo et réciproquement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel est le champ brûle que chantôme de
huit jours et je n'ai comme des héros
monde c'est de les aimer pour jour un
petit chauve et oui le maréchal pas de
france ou moins chaudes vers en revanche
en france et et qu'est-ce que tu étais
au mans sarthe et l école pratique met
fort m forget m d'ici nous disent ici 12
ainsi dix personnes y ayant très peu ici
au nom très bien née maurer ya trois
jours le programme et vous attend le
temps et vous bras
terry morris fleury fleury peuvent
toujours habité chimie et vous faites
vraiment une
une paire d'amis inséparables oui
oui je dis si on se fâche et le français
perdus mais on se fâche pas depuis
combien de temps ça dure alors
pratiquement oui plus depuis comité
comme égaux ça et pourquoi mais je ne
sais pas nos critères je revienne en est
un peu bourrique autant grotte
quand on est partis restent le plus
longtemps possible lui il est pareil
ayant encore plus riche que moi aussi je
veux si je veux parce que j'ai pas
autant qu'une commande
oui on voyait souvent oui moi je
descends au village mais j'ai pas de
moyen de locomotion mangé par une
voiture alors c'est c'est assez chargé
de ti qui conduit qui fait de se fâcher
lui le chauffeur est là vous partez
ensemble comme ça de temps en temps
ouais surtout à quelques gueules temps
on nous invite pour faire un peu les
machins ouvriers chaptes quelques
chansons grivoises le site quelques
monologues dit je t'aime public pauvreté
et on voit des banques non c'est sûr je
mets lui la nôtre âme citerne et ne
contient plus de monde ouais et comment
vous rendrai en voiture tout bois mais
dans quel état
robin du moment qui conduit la voiture
s'est il pas il est pas trop sous presse
que s'il est au dessous eh bien il
laisse la voiture sur place et et rend
demain rumeurs je ne vais pas rien ne
sourit pas souvent jeune et je ne
comprends pas le parler vrai ennemi ou
allant de november j'ai hurlé pris part
comme une forêt puisque laurel et hardy
aussi bien toujours pignon politique le
champagne à fait les mêmes avant vous
engueuler quelquefois à cause de la
politique
oui mais pourquoi pas on ne cherche pas
ça vient ainsi d'être tellement oui
alors niveau de ses sous le tapis
surtout ça serait quand même bien que
nous un jour là bon courage aux gonaives
spanu pendant au moins une heure et
demie en discuter puis il va des gets
manquent pas chez toi tu voudras pied
jeudi
si tu devais m'en fout puisque au cours
d'une amende
non tu es tellement dire justement de
pas mal de monde parce que j'ai quand
même des amis aussi d'autres dé bon foot
ou non mais qu'est ce qui vous sépare en
politique voter comment vous restez bien
il vaut tout rouge bandit ne peut pas
dire le contraire
moi je suis pas à boîte se fait dans le
milieu il y en a qui disent il faut que
ça change - joue donc ça dure comme ça
chantait tome paiements traite et jeudi
l'acception des sous qui paye
je viens non pas quand les caisses sont
mini pupilles et même disait bon coeur
alors on dit les capitalistes de
capitalistes mon fromage en a pas assez
il paraît que vous êtes allé à paris
dans la dernière monsieur maurice
ah oui j'allais oublier ton copain c'est
la première fois
oui on est allé à 8h08 heure 10 tonnes à
orly les bagages on les avait pas vus au
bout d'un moment on va arriver machin
qui tournait alors chaque camp les
attraper et puis et puis on a en étant à
visiter paris l'abus l'elysée on a vu le
musée du louvre
on est allé au moulin rouge de on est
allé à la défense par le rer qu'on
appelle l'aide du tramway
ouais là où il ya les escaliers qui
pilent pionner tard il a rapidement il
fallait signer un livre un livre d'or
d'orb je parle quoi la voix qui avait
alors moi j'ai me raser tout planté 2 1e
pour que les grives puissent venir
manger avec reese et et avoir deux ou
jeudi un ancien garde champêtre de la
commune dès que lui dans la drôme
maintenant j'ai pas dit jenny l'a vu
après il faut que ça ne me plaisait pas
la défense non non c'est toi des grandes
maisons
on en a vu qu'il avait des vitres à eau
à aa avait au moins a320 d'autre part on
est allé voir les magasins shoppers on
est allé voir les matraqueurs ne savais
pas que ça existait sa mère
khadir prit alors le show placé des
tonneaux et moi je vise les commotions
non mais quand même au sud puis le
monsieur il m'a dit faites votre choix
du santé j'ai dit bon gentil mais je
vais quand même pas où on va c'est pas
bon souvenir pareil ah oui oui vous avez
riez vivre non non non non non je me
sens perdu gros jamais vivre ici dans ma
campagne tranquille de la liberté fais
ce que je veux tellement bête et voilà
que mon petit bétail premier chien tous
mes vaches
qu'est-ce qui se passera le jour et où
l'un des deux partira cela c'est un
problème que tu fais six mois le premier
a beau jeu je suis comme j'étais pas
promis moi je m'habille je vais habiter
à broc faut oui parce que je vais
toucher le prix la question que je parle
tout seul vous voulez pas y penser à ça
non
on verra on verra quand savinois on a
toujours temps de le roi charles damon à
l'eau tiède chine devait sauter
[Musique]
alors moi j'ai oublié sur sept mois